all of a sudden i read that joey ramon i
didn't know this it was the 20th
anniversary of joey ramone's death and i
got really sad because
joey used to do our show i just loved
his whole attitude i loved the way he
sang i loved the way he came on our show
and talked
i even put a song of the ramones in my
movie remember the ramone song called
pinhead
you might remember it was in the movie
the famous movie private parts
there was a scene where i'm a first time
disc jockey at wrw
and i'm doing a little dance to this and
the general manager is staring at me
[Music]
and you remember this song i want to be
sedated
there's a weird thing about that song so
joey was always you know worried about
his voice so before every show he would
use a vaporizer to you know moisten his
throat
so he's trying to do something good
something healthy one night he's in
jersey there he's steaming his throat
and the boiling water it just exploded
the whole vaporizer exploded don't ask
me how that happened and
it scalded him he goes on he does the
show
he goes to the hospital he spent a week
in the hospital still did that show
yeah he was a trooper amazing he had
second and third degree burns on his
face and chest and he still did the show
geez joey had a couple of great moments
on our show one was um
he left a message for gary and joey was
really drunk
and it turns out this is a weird little
fact joey had gary's number because they
were dating the same woman at the time
i didn't know this yeah i asked him this
morning oh gary who was the woman you
you and joey were both dating and
he goes you wouldn't know but she was
really cute
she was really cute she was very cute
she was really cute
[Laughter]
fascinating hot i said hot she was very
hot
really hot very hot extremely hot
did you know joey and you were dating
her at the same time
gary we weren't very serious and i think
it was more like we crossed over you
know what i mean i don't think we were
dating at the same time i think we were
done dating and then she started dating
him
i think that woman had pretty unique
taste that's what i think
exotic i do want to give a shout out to
my old roommate though because we were i
was listening to the message and i
played it twice and i thought i was like
some whack job just leaving a [ __ ]
crank call on my machine and i literally
had my finger on the delete button
and my roommate i think that's joey
ramone i was like based on what
and then when i played it again i was
like oh yeah that's him yeah the phrase
he keeps saying which is impossible to
understand is welcome to my nightmare
all right gary is joey will you pick up
the phone
we awaken that white pad off
so that was one of his legendary moments
another legendary moment
was the fight joey had with his bandmate
marky this is one of the greatest fights
of all time
they accused each other of being drunks
joey accused marky of wearing a wig
and it got really ugly here's a little
clip from it this is joey and marky
ramone going at it he's a dry drunk
he's a dry drunk how are you
he says so are you how are you look i
don't care about this this is
stupid of course you do you brought it
up you were a wig
i don't know what he's talking about who
is a wig you know he's bald oh yeah
you you're bald yeah i wear a wig girls
are we pulsed by him
man i have no problem oh girls are
repulsed he's got tons of girls
you're living in a dream world okay
you're nothing marcy teresa
do your cooperation album okay thank you
i
i will i'll see you in hell
[Music]
and it always broke down into just a
fight
it was great yeah you women are repulsed
by you
these are band mates these are guys in a
band together
this is what happens in rock bands
anyway before they hung up we got them
to apologize to each other but it was
really hard for them
here's the big apology let's do it
together just give it a little head
start
we'll say one two three four we'll go i
apologize
okay all right ready all right one two
three four
i'll jump in right all right all right
one two three
four okay i apologize i apologize
all right ah wasn't that nice hey we had
closure yeah maybe we don't need judge
judy all right what a great moment
my wife walked into my office when i was
thinking about joey yesterday
and i told her the story she got
goosebumps because this this
be prepared to be really sad all right
this is just a heartbreaking
story so joey got cancer at the end the
story goes that joey died while he was
listening to the u2 song
in a little while you know that song in
a little while
joey's in his hospital bed he knows he's
close to the end
he knew he knew he was dying he wanted
to hear this u2 song
as the song ended joey passed away the
last
conscious thing he wanted to experience
wasn't a meal wasn't
you know it was this song he loved music
so much amazing yeah
isn't that an amazing story joey ramon
20 years gone we miss you and thanks for
the great music and the great radio that
you did for us and i thought we should
honor him